>> BUT FIRST, LAWMAKERS
DEMANDING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
WHAT WAS POTENTIALLY THE WORLD’S
FIRST CORONAVIRUS SUPER SPREADER
EVENT, THE WASHINGTON POST
REPORTS MORE THAN 9,000 AT LEADS
ATTENDED THE MILITARY WORLD
GAMES IN WUHAN, CHINA IN OCTOBER
2019 INCLUDING 280 FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
MANY OF THEM COMPLAINED ABOUT
COVID-LIKE SYMPTOMS TWO MONTHS
BEFORE CHINA EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED
THE VIRUS’ EXISTENCE.
IT COMES AMID CONCERNS THAT
CORONAVIRUS LEAKED FROM A
RESEARCH LAB THERE.
HERE’S WHAT TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
MICHAEL BURR DRESSMICHAEL BURGES
BARTIROMO LAST WEEK.
MARIA:  WILL THERE BE ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CCP
ALLOWING THIS DEADLY DISEASE TO
ESCAPE ITS BORDERS AND COVERING
IT UP.
>> MY OPINION IS THERE SIMPLY
HAS TO BE AND WHETHER THAT’S
DONE ON THE TRADE FRONT, WHETHER
THAT’S DONE ON SOME TYPE OF
REMUNERATION THAT HAS TO OCCUR.
WITH THIS ILLNESS, DIFFERENT
FROM SARS 1   20 YEARS AGO,
THERE THERE WAS A JUMP FROM A
BAT TO A CAT TO PEOPLE.
THIS ONE, THERE WAS NO
INTERMEDIARY WHICH REALLY,
REALLY DOES POINT TO THE FACT
LAB MANUFACTURER, LAB RELEASE,
ACCIDENTAL, ON PURPOSE, THAT
WILL HAVE TO BE DETERMINED.
>> KANSAS REPUBLICAN SENATOR
ROGER MARSHALL WROTE TO
SECRETARY ABOUT WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WAS AWARE OF AMERICAN
ATHLETES FALLING ILL AFTER
RETURNING FROM THE GAMES IN
WUHAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT?
WHAT DO WE WANT TO KNOW?
MICHAEL BURGESS THAT WE HEARD IS
A DOCTOR.
BUT CANDIDLY, CHINA HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN FORTHRIGHT IN WHAT’S
GOING ON.
>> YOU’RE RIGHT, JASON.
AND I KNOW IF YOU GO BACK TO
YOUR DAYS AT CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, YOU CAN
SMELL A COVERUP AND THIS SMELLS
LIKE A COVERUP.
EVERY DAY, THE TIMELINE GETS
BACKED UP.
REALIZING THAT THE MIDDLE OF
JANUARY THE CHINESE, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WERE SAYING
THERE WAS NO PERSON TO PERSON
TRANSMISSION.
NOW, WE KNOW PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES HAD POSITIVE
ANTIBODIES IN DECEMBER OF 2019.
WE KNOW THAT THE WUHAN WAS
STARTING TO COVER UP THIS
PARTICULAR INCIDENT AS WELL IN
OCTOBER 2019, THOUSANDS OF
SOLDIERS FROM HUNDREDS OF
COUNTRIES GATHERED IN WUHAN,
CHINA FOR A MILITARY OLYMPICS.
SEVERAL WEEKS LATER, MANY OF
THEM DEVELOPED SYMPTOMS.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY DESCRIBED
WUHAN, A CITY OF 11 MILLION
PEOPLE AS A GHOST TOWN.
SINCE AT LEAST OCTOBER, THE
PEOPLE OF CHINA WERE COVERING
THIS UP.
AND WHAT I WANT TO KNOW AS A
SENATOR IS WHY DIDN’T THE CDC
CHECK INTO THIS?
WHY DIDN’T THE HHS CHECK INTO
THIS?
WHY WASN’T INTELLIGENCE WORKING
ON THIS?
WERE THEY PART OF THE COVERUP?
DO THEY HAVE SOME GUILT IN THE
SITUATION AS WELL?
SO I’M JUST STUNNED TO FIND OUT
THIS NEW INFORMATION EVERY WEEK.
>> NOW, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS WARNING THAT WE MAY NEVER
QUITE KNOW WITH CERTAINITY
WHAT’S HAPPENING.
BUT WHAT ARE THEY DOING, IF
ANYTHING, THAT YOU CAN SEE FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AS A UNITED
STATES SENATOR, TO ACTUALLY PUSH
THE CHINESE REGIME TO ACTUALLY
BEING MORE CANDID AND A
FORTHRIGHT WITH OUR
INVESTIGATORS?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY NOT ENOUGH.
THEY DO HAVE AN INVESTIGATION
UNDERWAY BUT I’M NOT EXPECTING
THEM TO FIND ANYTHING THAT WE
DON’T ALREADY KNOW.
JASON, WHAT THIS REMINDS ME OF
IS, YOU ARREST THE GODFATHER AND
ALL THE WITNESSES START DYING.
AND IN THIS CASE, THE WITNESSES
ARE THE GENOMIC BANKS THAT WE
HAVE SITTING OF OUT THERE.
IN JANUARY OF 2020 -- FEBRUARY
OF 2020, THE NIH ERASED 500
GENETIC SEQUENCES  FROM THE BAT
LADY THAT SHE WAS STOREING IN
THE NIH LABORATORY BANK.
GOING BACK TO TON, IN SEPTEMBER,
-- 2019, IN SEPTEMBER, THE BAT
LADY ERASED A BUNCH OF VIRUSES
FROM THE LABORATORY BANK WE HAD
ACCESS TO.
THE WITNESSES ARE ALL DYING.
THERE MAY BE SOMETHING ON THE
CLOUD SERVER WE CAN DIG UP.
WE’RE FINDING BITS AND PIECES
EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE TO START HOLDING CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE CAN SANCTION THEM.
WE CAN SEIZE THEIR ASSETS WHAM
THEY NEED IS PUBLIC SHAMING,
THAT WE HAVE TO SHAME THEM, NOT
JUST THE UNITED STATES BUT WE
NEED OTHER COUNTRIES TO SHAME
THEM AS WELL.
WE NEED TO BRING MANUFACTURING
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES, DO
ALL THOSE THINGS TO PUBLICLY
BATTLE THEM.
>> WHAT SORT OF CONFIDENCE LEVEL
DO YOU HAVE IN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION?
CHINA MADE A BIG DEAL, TRYING TO
GET INTO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
NOW THAT THEY’RE THERE, THERE’S
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST THAT THEY HAVE.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION HAS A VERY
REPUTATION, -- VERY BAD
REPUTATION, THAT THEY’VE BEEN
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY CHINA.
THE LEADER IS A HAND PICKED
PERSON FROM CHINA.
CHINA IS NOT DUMB.
THEY WENT INTO -- TEDROS IS HIS
NAME, THEY WENT INTO HIS
COUNTRY, THEY LOANED HIM MONEY
LIKE A LOAN SHARK WOULD LOAN
MONEY AND THEY GOT HIM THE
POSITION AS HEAD OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE FAILED.
AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED, WHETHER
IT’S THE QUAD OR G-7 OR THE G-20
BUT WE NEED MULTIPLE NATIONS
LOOKING INTO THIS AND HOLDING
CHINA ACCOUNTABLE AND STARTING
THE SHAMING IN SOME WAY.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED THAT THEY
INVENTED THE BIOTERRORISM
WEAPON.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED THEY
LEAKED IT FROM THE LAB.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED THAT THEY
COVERED IT UP.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED THEY
CAN’T EVEN MAKE THE VACCINE
RIGHT NOW.
SO THIS PUBLIC SHAMING HAS TO
COME TO FRUITION.
>> SO THE CONCERN IS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS GIVING
THIS SOME LIP SERVICE BUT NOT
ACTUALLY DOING ANYTHING.
LISTEN TO WHAT THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, JOHN RATCLIFFE,
HAD TO SAY ABOUT THIS WHEN HE
SPOKE WITH MARIA BARTIROMO
RECENTLY.
MARIA:  WHAT SHOULD BE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AS A RESULT OF THE
CCP ALLOWING THIS DEADLY VIRUS
TO ESCAPE ITS BORDERS AND WHY
HASN’T BIDEN BROUGHT UP THE
ORIGINS OF COVID WITH XI JINPING
NOW SIX MONTHS INTO HIS TERM?
>> YEAH, AS YOU KNOW, MARIA,
AFTER THE ELECTION I WROTE AN
OP-ED CALLING CHINA OUR NUMBER
ONE NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT AND
TALKED ABOUT AS THE PERSON WHO
HAS SEEN MORE INTELLIGENCE THAN
ANYONE IN THE COUNTRY FOR THE
PAST WE’RE, HOW CLEAR IT IS THAT
THEY’RE NOT JUST AN ADVERSARY
BUT SOMEONE THAT WANTS TO
SUPPLANT US AS THE WORLD’S SUPER
POWER.
AS WE SHARED THE INFORMATION
WITH THE INCOMING BIDEN FOLK,
OUR HOPE IS THEY WOULDN’T HAVE
JUST TOUGH RHETORIC, THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TOUGH ACTION.
CLEARLY, THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE.
>> YOUR REACTION, SENATOR?
>> YOUR LISTENERS NEED TO
REALIZE THAT CHINA WANTS TO OWN
THE WORLD.
THAT IS THEIR GOAL RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU POINTED OUT MANY TIMES,
THEY STEAL $500 BILLION OF
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FROM US
EVERY YEAR, 90% OF THE
COUNTERFEITS AND FENTANYL THAT
COME INTO OUR COUNTRY IS MADE IN
CHINA.
IT’S MAYBE WORSE THAN I EXPECTED
WHEN I GOT INTO THE HOUSE.
NOW THE HOUSE AND A SENATE AS
WELL, WE HAVE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
IT’S GOING TO BE PAINFUL.
IT’S GOING TO BE PAINFUL FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND THE WORLD TO
SAY WE CAN’T DO BUSINESS WITH
YOU WHEN YOU LIE, CHEAT AND
STEAL FROM AMERICANS SO WE’LL
HAVE TO HAVE SOME TOUGH LOVE
WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING WITH
CHINA, FOCUS ON BRINGING THE
SUPPLY CHAINS BACK TO THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVE TO START BY DOING THAT
YESTERDAY.
>> VERY QUICKLY, SENATOR, BEFORE
WE GO TO COMMERCIAL BREAK, THE
ECO HEALTH ALLIANCE THAT MARIA
BARTIROMO HAS TALKED ABOUT
EXTENSIVELY, OUR GOVERNMENT GAVE
THEM AN AWFUL LOT OF MONEY.
THERE’S A LOT OF SUSPICION
THERE.
>> EXACTLY.
IF I COULD CALL ONE WITNESS TO
OUR BIPARTISAN HEALTHCARE,
HEALTH COMMITTEE, I WOULD LIKE
TO CALL PETER DASZAK WHO HEADS
THAT.
WE NEED TO FOLLOW THE MONEY.
IT WASN’T JUST FROM NIH BUT ALSO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE WAS
GIVING HIM TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AS WELL.
THEY WERE RESEARCHING
BIOTERRORIST WEAPONS.
I THINK THE CORONAVIRUS,
COVID-19 FITS INTO A MAN MADE
VIRUS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE VIRUS, IT
LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
FRANKENSTEIN WOULD HAVE MADE SO
WE’VE GOT SOME DEEP THINGS TO
DIVE INTO.
>> YOU’RE RIGHT, FOLLOW THE
MONEY.
SENATOR, STAY RIGHT THERE.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE AIMING TO
EXPAND SOCIAL PROGRAMS AND PAY
FOR CHILD CARE, HEALTHCARE AND
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH TAX HIKES.
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO PUSH IT ALL
THROUGH USING RECONCILIATION?
WE’LL DIVE INTO THAT NEXT WITH
THE SENATOR.
STAY WITH US.
♪
MARIA:  DO YOU THINK HE HAS THE
SUPPORT OF ALL DEMOCRATS?
WILL HE BE ABLE TO PUSH THIS
THROUGH RECONCILIATION
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS SAY?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S GOING TO
BE A LONG, HARD SLOG FOR THEM TO
TRY TO INCREASE TAXES BY THIS
MUCH ON THE AMERICAN PUBLIC FOR
THINGS THAT REALLY WOULD GO WAY
BEYOND WHAT I WOULD THINK IS IN
THE SCOPE OF GOVERNMENT.
THERE’S SO MANY MANY LIBERAL
PROGRAMS IN HERE, VERY
EXPENSIVE, THE WHOLE GREEN BAD
DEAL WITH THE RECYCLABLE
CAFETERIA TRAYS, I THINK HE’S
GOING TO HAVE A HARD TIME DOING
IT AND IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
QUICKLY.
JASON:  THAT’S WYOMING SENATOR
JOHN BARRASSO ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S SPENDING PLANS AND
CHALLENGES THE THEY FACE IN
CONGRESS.
A NEARLY $1 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL STRUCK BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF SENATORS HAS
SOME POE POTENTIAL BUT DEMOCRATS
WANT TO INCLUDE A LOT OF ITEMS
FROM A $715 BILLION
TRANSPORTATION AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL PASSED BY
THE HOUSE LAST WEEK.
WE’RE BACK WITH KANSAS
REPUBLICAN SENATOR, ROGER
MARSHALL.
SENATOR, ARE THEY GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PASS THIS THROUGH
RECONCILIATION?
I MEAN, HOW DO THEY JUSTIFY ALL
THESE NUMBERS?
BECAUSE THEY KEEP ADDING THE
TRILLIONS UPON TRILLIONS.
>> YEAH, JASON, FIRST OF ALL,
YOU BETTER GRAB YOUR WALLET
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN’S
ADMINISTRATION WANTS IN THAT
WALLET OF YOURS, WANTS YOU TO
WRITE BIG CHECKS TO THEM.
LOOK, I THINK THEY SPENT MOST OF
THEIR POLITICAL CAPITAL ON THIS.
YOU KNOW A SAYING MY DAD TALK
ME, FOOL ME ONCE, SHAME ON YOU,
FOOL ME TWICE, SHAME ON ME AND
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE HAS FOOLED
US THREE TIMES AND THEY THREW A
BUNCH OF SENATORS UNDER THE BUS,
INCLUDING DEMOCRATS, SENATORS
JOE MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA.
JOE GETS MOST OF THE INK.
KYRSTEN HAS BEEN ABLE -- I’VE
SEEN HER TAKE NOTES, TAKE
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOUR OR FIVE
SENSE S TOSSER AT A TIME AND I
WOULD SPEAK TO HER ABOUT A
HEALTHCARE ISSUE AND SHE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HE RECITE THE WHOLE
THING BACK TO US.
I DON’T THINK THE MODERATES IN
THE PARTY ARE GOING TO BE HAPPY
ABOUT THE WAY THEY GOT THROUGH
UNDER THE -- THROWN UNDER THE
BUS HERE AND THEY’RE NOT GOING
TO BE HAPPY ABOUT RAISING YOUR
TAXES.
JASON:  SENATOR, CANDIDLY, ONE
OF MY CONCERNS IS REPUBLICANS
SEEM TO WORRY ABOUT THE DEBT AND
DEFICIT, ONLY WHEN THEY’RE IN
THE MINORITY.
IF YOU LOOK BACK OVER THE LAST
10 YEARS, WHEN IT WAS
OBAMA/BIDEN F YOU LOOK AT THE
SPENDING MONEY AND THE BASE
BUDGET, THAT NUMBER IS REALLY UP
NEARLY MORE THAN 50%.
THIS IS THE DOMESTIC BASE
SPENDING.
DOESN’T INCLUDE ANY OF THE OTHER
STIMULUS AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS.
THAT’S THE 10 10-YEAR NUMBER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEBT, IT’S
BASICALLY DOUBLED IN THAT 10
OF-YEAR PERIOD AND, LOOK,
REPUBLICANS HAD CONTROL FOR SOME
OF THOSE YEARS AND THE CONCERN
IS WE TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH MORE
WE’RE GOING TO SPEND, BUT
SENATOR, WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT WE’RE GOING TO CUT AND CURB
BACK?
>> YEAH, WELL, JASON, CERTAINLY
AS LONG AS DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND CONTROL THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE, THAT
CONVERSATION’S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY’VE ALREADY BORROWED, WHAT,
$2 TRILLION THIS YEAR AND THEY
WANT TO BORROW ANOTHER $6
TRILLION.
SO WHEN I CAME TO D.C. FOUR
YEARS AGO, I THOUGHT WE HAD A
PLAN.
MUCH LIKE TURNING AROUND A
BUSINESS THAT’S UPSIDE DOWN, THE
FIRST THING WE HAD TO DO WAS
GROW THE BUSINESS SO WE CUT
TAXES, DESPITE CUTTING TAXES WE
ACTUALLY GREW REVENUES FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
YOU HAVE TO START DEALINGS
THINGS DOWN.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO PICK AND
CHOOSE?
I GUESS HAVE ANYBODY CALL ME UP
AND SAY I WANT TO CUT MY
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES, IT’S GOING
TO BE A TOUGH CONVERSATION TO V
THIS IS THE PROBLEM THAT KEEPS
ME UP LATE AT NIGHT AND WHETHER
YOU WANT A STRONG MILITARY,
STRONG SCHOOLS, STRONG ROADS AND
BRIDGES, THE FUTURE OF THE
BALANCED BUDGET IS WHAT’S GOING
TO IMPACT IT MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE.
SO I AGREE COMPLETELY BUT IT’S A
TOUGH, TOUGH POLITICAL
CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
I THINK IT WILL TAKE A SECOND
TERM PRESIDENT WITH A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE.
JASON:  WELL, SENATOR, I THINK
YOU’RE RIGHT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
CUT TAXES, THE REVENUE TO THE
TREASURY WENT UP.
BUT IF YOU DON’T COUPLE THAT
WITH CUTTING SPENDING, THEN YOU
CONTINUE TO EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM.
AND AMERICANS ARE GOING TO FEEL
THINGS HERE REAL SOON.
THEY’RE ALSO FEELING IT AS THE
GAS PUMP WHERE THE PRICE OF GAS
IS BASICALLY $1 HIGHER THAN IT
WAS A YEAR AGO.
BUT SENATOR, I WISH YOU NOTHING
BUT THE BEST THIS INDEPENDENCE
DAY.
I HOPE YOU, YOUR FAMILY AND THE
GOOD PEOPLE OF CAN KANSAS HAVE A
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE LIKE
THE REST OF AMERICA BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT, THIS IS STILL THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF
THE PLANET BUT WE’VE GOT TO
FIGURE THIS ONE OUT.
>> THANKS, JASON.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
HAPPY INDEPENDENCE DAY TO YOU,
YOUR FAMILY AND ALL YOUR
LISTENERS.
JASON:  THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.